for me just observing the trial it was
interesting
that first of all is a really
raw and honest exploration of
intimate relationship between two people
oh yeah it was interesting to watch I
suppose I haven't watched that kind of
thing
it made me think about what makes for a
good relationship
all the all the many things we've
already talked about in this
conversation
it was useful for that but also there
was raw recordings of two humans
interaction what did you think about
that that there's recordings it's kind
of interesting the act of recording your
partner yeah and not not the ethics of
that or so on but the fact that you have
this data made me wonder like if I
recorded myself how would I sound like
you might record yourself no but here
with microphones but when you're in
private yeah you wonder
like I I had a a bit of a fight with a
friend uh last week
and I wondered which one of us was the
I would love to hear the
recording because we were a little bit I
think we're a little bit rude to each
other and I wonder how it went wrong I
love that you asked yourself that
question that's so useful we made up the
next day and we I think both agreed to
not ever talk about it but I want to
bury it deep yeah you know I record my
couple sessions and one of the primary
purposes of that is so that
after if they start to get nasty with
each other in the session I can stop it
and I can say what was that right and
most of the time that what you're
describing is so useful because we don't
see ourselves we have no idea that we
just came off as critical we think we're
being completely reasonable and
thoughtful you know whenever somebody's
sort of retelling an argument they got
and they said and then you know I was
just caring and just asked I mean why is
there a reason you didn't you know
something like that if they can actually
see themselves they realize no their jaw
was clenched their voice was raised they
actually called a name sometimes they're
shocked
uh so just a quick just the Linger on it
the you labeled
and Amber Heard as a three six code Type
going back to our discussion which can
mean that quote she's heavily concerned
with image prone to treating others with
cruelty unable to admit responsibility
for wrongdoing and prone to
externalizing blame and then I also went
into the the mmpi to list three six
includes anxiety tension rigidity fear
of criticism
suppress hostility merging and passive
or episodic aggression
suspiciousness egocentricity what else
projection
what can you say about that code that is
not captured in the different
personality disorders
um what are we supposed to do that from
a forensic psychology perspective and
what what what are we supposed to do
that in general forget the 3-6 in
general these kinds of code types in
that context in the context of a trial
if I'm understanding you correctly it's
sort of what's the point of these code
types yeah
um thank you for asking the question
better but
I don't know what I'm doing I just I
just actually honestly really find mmpi
too fast I love that you do yeah I love
that you get it because I just to me
it's such a uh it's almost unbelievable
that humans created it
um but I think that goes back to that
empirical key method of creating
something that'll enabled it to be as
robust as it is and something that is
very difficult to beat if not impossible
um
but the code types really so it depends
on in any forensic case what really
matters is the legal psycho legal
questions so what is the legal question
and then what is the psychologist's
responsibility in assisting with
whatever question they're being asked
and there are some questions we can't
answer some that we can
you don't always need to provide a
diagnosis when you're asked to provide a
report it depends on the jurisdiction it
depends on the statute some
jurisdictions actually require a
diagnosis in this case I was asked to
provide a diagnosis so when I'm
considering a diagnosis you're
integrating multiple different sources
of information you're integrating an
examining self-report you are adding
collateral data usually I wasn't able to
obtain collateral interviews in this
case and that was the decision of the
Court they said no collateral interviews
but typically that would be something
that you would add you're looking at
records ideally from birth up until the
day that the alleged injury occurred and
I'm speaking now specifically to a
personal injury evaluation or something
where somebody is claiming that they
were harmed psychologically
um but you want as many records as
possible to show how a person functioned
before that event occurred and how they
functioned after and you want it to show
Financial functioning physical
functioning academic functioning
basically where is there evidence that
something in their life changed
um where is there evidence that harm
occurred other than from what they're
telling you and uh in addition to all of
those records that you're reviewing in
addition to their self-report then
you're also going to give some of these
tests like the mmpi so the code types
are really that that strength of the
mmpi2 it gives you really nuanced
information about a person's personality
now again you're not going to use the
mmpi2 or any other test by itself to
diagnose someone or you know decide that
the person is telling the truth not
telling the truth it is just another
piece of data and when it's working the
way it's supposed to It lines up really
nicely with all of the other data you're
getting including what you've observed
from the person during your interview
with them the information they're giving
you or inconsistencies with the
information they're giving you the
consistency or inconsistency of their
self-report from the records what the
records themselves say etc etc so it's
adding it's helping you clarify and
clarify and clarify the picture yeah
just dialing it down more and more
you're just making sure that it is as
accurate as possible
okay so given how huge this trial was
given how eloquent you were you were I
know you don't think of it that way but
from a public perspective you were like
the star
because of how loud I mean you know uh
I'm pretty sure Camille's the star
Camille is also incredible I've got a
chance to interact with her she's
somebody that uh
really inspires me by how good she is at
her job how much she loves her job and
how much the fame the money whatever has
not affected the basic core Integrity of
who she is as a human being so she's
also uh she's also incredible okay uh
how what's the what's the takeaway for
you personally from The Trial uh how's
it made you a better person how is it
changing changed or solidified who you
are as a psychologist as a forensic
psychologist clinical psychologist and
so on
wow uh I mean a lot happened in my life
around that trial leading up to the
trial after the trial
um
so let's tackle forensic psychologists
first sure okay so in terms of forensic
psychology
um I am grateful to that trial for
really strengthening my abilities
um
these Stakes were so high that I took
you know I was retained about two years
prior to the trial so I really delved
deep into the academic side of forensic
psychology and making sure that
um I was adhering as closely as possible
to standard practices best practice
recommendations for this specific type
of an examination it was intellectually
awesome and challenging I feel like my
brain was on fire for a full year
leading up to the trial and that can be
really really fun it was just
challenging but I am really proud of the
work I did I think the stakes were
really high it's serious work it's
important that it's done well and
accurately and
I felt really good about it so I have
some of those lessons carried through to
your practice now to both research and
uh some of the things you're doing in
terms of helping couples
uh no I I mean I just
you know my practice hasn't changed that
much
uh this was more uh just something that
was more it demanded so much more of my
time than my typical forensic work does
and personal injury cases are in cases
where there is an allegation of trauma
or psychological harm tend to be super
labor intensive this given um the
magnitude and how long it had been going
on in the back and forth required a ton
of work before the trial as well so it
pulled me away from the practice I think
it's been nice to go back a bit if okay
so now personally
um I've learned some things I've learned
that I need to slow down a little bit
so this took a lot from you it took a
lot but it was really the culmination I
feel like there are these hoops we jump
through again and again you know
academic challenges that we continue to
meet and then there's a next one and a
next one and a next one and in the
beginning like when you're getting into
college or applying to grad schools you
don't really realize this is going to be
a never-ending thing especially if I
continue with research or forensic work
I love it because it is so academic you
know you're writing these 75-page
reports and with citations and
um you have to be accurate it feels like
I'm doing giant board exams again and
again and again
um it never ends but that feeling I
think you and I were talking about how
it's fun to doubt yourself because it
pushes you to do better work
um but so if you keep having high stakes
you're going to work all the time work
yourself in the ground constantly be
thinking I'm about oh this question I'm
not sure if I fully know the answer and
all the research behind that so I should
go there
and again super fun
but
I don't just do forensic psychology all
day I also have own a clinic I provide
therapy I've been providing therapy for
15 years so what happens is you have
clients who maybe you've stopped seeing
but when they have a crisis in their
lives they reach out to you again even
if it's seven years later so you've
accumulated hundreds of clients who at
any given time are going to reach out
when they're in crisis whether or not
you're working on a federal case or in
Virginia for this and
that is never going to be something easy
to Grapple with because I feel that I am
letting somebody down I know I am
because these are people I genuinely
care about and they care about me and
they trust me
and I want to be able to be there for
them I know that it's disappointing if I
can't be and it's also very difficult
to separate out the Professional Therapy
relationship from loving someone who
you've seen through some of the most
difficult parts of their lives and I can
explain that to people all day long but
it doesn't necessarily mean that it's
going to be easy for someone to accept
when I can't talk to them
and they just found out you know their
husband was leading a double life or you
know their sister just died and I can't
even get on a call because I'm getting
maybe 15 messages like that a day
and have to testify and have to run my
practice
um so I think that was why I need to
slow down this case I was doing all of
that
um
and then like the academic load or the
work involved was just tremendous
um and some stuff happened like my dad
he started having his cognitive decline
I got a medical diagnosis that is stress
induced
um I really thought I was getting away
with it I I really believed that people
who talk like a lot about self-care were
kind of full of and just didn't
know how to push themselves I still
believe in pushing ourselves
but I think I
I
kind of traversed into an area and
without realizing it where I was no
longer pushing myself to challenge
myself or see what I was capable of I
was almost pushing myself like as a
necessity because I didn't know what
else to do anymore
just an obligation
um it wasn't even yeah I wasn't pushing
myself to do
the debt herd case reminded me of that
feeling of pushing myself to do
something I wasn't sure I was capable of
and overcoming that challenge that was
rewarding
but when you're piling that on with like
running a business and all these other
things and trying to be perfect at all
of them that just starts to become like
a feeling of necessity and it's not
healthy
that said you somehow managed to hold it
all together to put forward a mask for
performance and like you said still take
care of all these clients because you're
the most important person in their lives
for many of them
um is there is there a secret to that
was there any hacks
is there uh sleep a lot I don't get no
and honestly
I it's not 100 it's not how I
it's a work in progress right I I don't
have an answer for
I wouldn't want my life to be any other
way I you know I wouldn't have had the
opportunity to work on this case if I
hadn't established my practice and had
Outreach and um
so I I can't figure out like which piece
you take it out without it all crumbling
yeah but I would love to have a little
more down time so it all kind of works
together in this
passion is the fuel that
uh that's behind all of it probably
that's probably the reason you haven't
lost your mind quite yet maybe yeah
maybe unless I mean it depends who you
ask what
about the stress of just being in the
public eye has that been difficult for
you
that's a lovely question thank you for
asking it because I'm
it is nice to talk to you about this
because I feel like you probably
understand it a little bit
um that was something I was absolutely
unprepared for uh like I said I had no
idea how many people were watching when
I testified I
I had no idea and I got off the stand I
kind of staggered to the back room and
truly thought about lying down on the
floor because I was so exhausted and uh
you know I'd been up studying on my
stuff terrified that I was gonna forget
some statistic about the mmpi too it's
gonna be so great it's great for me it's
gonna be great for people to hear this
that you're human you're too flawless
that you're that's extremely stressful
for many many hours I wondered how you
could sit there for so many hours and
stay so focused and listen so well it's
so difficult well I mean I could talk
about that too at the moment I came to
almost like came back to my body and
realized where I was and just wanted it
to stop and felt like I was burning
alive I just was thinking I don't want
to do this anymore I don't want to do
this anymore is this going to stop and
then another question came and I just
had to get back to it but uh so after I
testified the first time I went in that
back room I I might have laid down on
the ground it's kind of a blur I mean I
might have I do remember that Wayne
Dennison uh one of the senior managing
Partners at Brown Rudnick who is a
phenomenal guy and absolutely brilliant
I will be indebted in for life because
um I trusted him I trusted him and that
made all the difference in probably how
I testified but he came in the back and
he was looking at his phone and he said
you're on the cover of time something on
you know like Apple news
and I thought I mean I really I thought
he was messing with me
um I thought it was it was his joke way
of saying like I did great